this is a cue for air in the world's
biggest democracy the hunt for oxygen is
getting more
urgent
the man on the right says they're not
filling up the cylinders completely
lives are at stake and every extra
breath of oxygen
counts right now a young man is pleading
brother my grandmother is on her
deathbed and the hospital sent me
please fill mine he's lucky he's pushed
his way to the top of a very long
queue and got away with it all
businesses with oxygen supplies have
been told to give them over for medical
use
how now ill is she if we don't give
oxygen she will die in hospital
hospitals say no oxygen so you're taking
this to the hospital yes
these cylinders have become the lifeline
for many indians
but harshit's grandmother needs them
filled every two hours to keep her alive
and the hospital is in another state it
is very far
and no one is allowed to go inside my
grandma inside and my younger brother
inside only
surrender no one else how long
[Music]
across the city there's another line but
the shop hasn't yet got its oxygen
delivery
and some of these people have been
waiting since three in the morning
they're still here eight hours later
to do this thing but they didn't do
anything
the government of delhi didn't do
anything and that's why people are
suffering
in every shop there is no oxygen there
is no oxygen
black market is on high
black market is on high when you go to
hospital there is no
oxygen in hospital delhi is under
lock down now but part of the criticism
is that they lifted it far too early and
there were
crowds of people all gathering at
political rallies
indians are now dependent on cylinders
partly because
several governments have restricted
oxygen manufacturing here in the capital
to just small-scale industries they've
spent only
around two percent of the country's gdp
or income on the health
industry and we visited multiple
chemists
all out of covert medicines do you have
any remedies over there
for coronavirus do you have any of the
medicine
have you got rem disavow no not
overlapping
not available
there's no availability on any retail
store because they're out of stock
because of out of stuff because of low
production because of their
more many more circumstances
it's meant charities have had to step in
to provide oxygen for very sick people
who can't get it elsewhere it's all on a
very small
scale but for some it's vital
she's been under this tree for two days
cared for by her son obviously
struggling
the family wanted us to show this they
want their own government
and others to see what's happening here
and everywhere now toxin oxygen
available in all hospitals often not
available
others are running dangerously low
harpreet has probably only about half an
hour of oxygen
left yeah it's almost exhausted you can
see over here
their load arrives in the nick of time
this hand-to-mouth surviving because
many believe the government declared
covert victory far too early and didn't
plan ahead
the lack of oxygen generating units
means hospitals and their patients are
reliant on supplies coming in from
far too few plants around the country
in this hospital they have less than a
handful of tanks and their storage is
being used up every few hours
so the head of the hospitals decided to
buy his own oxygen manufacturing unit
so we can order five plants so that can
just have a capacity of almost like
5000 cylinders a day he sourced one from
turkey
and is hoping it'll be here within seven
to ten days
now since we have experienced it that in
times of crisis
we can land up in such a situation where
the life of the patient is put to risk
i think we need to take some steps so
that we become more independent
and not depend on the weak supply chain
mechanism which is there
existing currently but india is still in
the grip of a coronavirus nightmare
and tens of thousands of its citizens
can't think days ahead
whilst they're struggling to breathe
hour to hour
alex crawford sky news delhi